2021 has been
very much a health journey for me
2020 i had the year-end like top 20
lessons of 2020
and i felt like i got a a lot of them uh
and it doesn't mean i didn't get lessons
this year but the but the really like
predominant thing that i've been dealing
with this year has been health so i went
and i got some tests done to check my
hormones and see if things were off
and he was like oh your thyroid's off
then he's trying to chase it down with
um i tried a natural
thyroid medicine it made me feel sick
and you know just all kinds of stuff and
he was like you know you should probably
see a functional doctor in the meantime
had interviewed ben greenfield and so he
recommended like five or six tests and
um so that kind of all was happening
simultaneously with getting a functional
doctor the functional doctor came just
after he recommended those things so i
ordered all the tests and i got them and
which was great because it's what she
would have ordered anyway
and so she did add on a couple more
which we end up talking about a lot in
um my health download with ben
but one of them was a provoked heavy
metals test so it basically showed that
i had really really really really high
levels of
mercury i had other elevated elements to
like lead and thalium and cessium and
something else and anyway so metals were
an issue in the middle of it all
i ran a marathon so marathons are really
hard on the body i remember
when all this started the beginning of
the year and hearing about the thyroid
and probably it was i think it was in
april
and
i was like oh my god that's the answer i
have been suspicious that something has
been off with my hormones for years
and i remember a few years earlier it
was like just after it was like two
beginning of 2018 i had like changed my
job changed my relationship changed my
living circumstances so much stuff had
changed and i like i had gained a few
pounds and i was like hmm i wonder if
this is just you know age my hair
doesn't seem quite the same like is it
age maybe it's because i'm not racing
anymore like there was all kinds of
things and i just attributed it to that
it was nothing super dramatic but it was
noticeable to me and being really really
into health and wellness like i paid
really close attention to my body i'm
pretty body aware um
and so then when that came through i
look back and i'm like man it is when i
go through something really emotional so
the beginning of 17 it was like it
always seems to fall some somewhere
between like four and six months after
emotional stuff so
november of 17 like everything changed
end of november and then you know i
started noticing at the beginning of 18
like march time april and then with this
you know i had a you know really bad
breakup in the middle of 2020 and then
like november
time november-ish i remember thinking
man something feels like it's shifted
again like a little bit more weight gain
a little bit like even my face didn't
even look the same there's just so much
stuff that was shifting and and then the
cycle was the thing that really got me
into the doctor because i just
i would give myself the same attitude
that i would give other people which is
just try harder like maybe you should
just do this maybe
age means you just can't have as eat as
much maybe it means you need to do a
training try a different different kind
of training
and i guess the the kind of the sum of
it all is i would just say if you feel
like something's going on with your body
because i literally thought to myself
maybe something's weird with my hormones
um
and especially if you've had really big
life changes
um
job living illnesses
breakups all kinds of stuff anything
that's going to be emotionally taxing um
just be aware that it's not just
happening up here it's happening
everywhere
and um so that'll be kind of part of one
of the big lessons from from 2021 with
the health journey but listen to the
body you're really smart you're really
intuitive the health journey is a
lifelong one and um but it's worth it
i'd like to go into the top 10
health lessons
of
2021.
so the first one i'm gonna start with
lesson number one
rest rest is just not something that i'm
very good at it's not i i'm always
thinking to myself try harder do more
do another workout i mean shoot in my
book pretty intense i write about two
workouts a day and you know i'm just all
about like putting in the effort and at
the end of the day
um
there's so much
so much good that happens internally as
well as externally with the rest i mean
even just from a physicality standpoint
when you work out and tear those muscles
apart like you're kind of in a state of
inflammation never mind what that does
to the insides with adrenals and
cortisol and all that it's it's it can
get i think it just really was
detrimental to me to to do so much for
so long like being someone that
i mean wrote about no rest days like i
don't take rest days um they naturally
happen as and they do it's not like i
don't ever take a day off but i used to
just think they just happen and so you
know my life is a little bit more
structured now i mean i used to
structure it in a way that i'm home a
little bit more so you know i have to
really force myself to take a rest day
but i am learning how how critical they
are and then coming back after rest i
mean my god you really do feel good
lesson number two is walk after you eat
so
i used a continuous blood glucose
monitor
this summer for a couple of months
and it was just so informational and
what it's obviously telling you it was
like you'd scan it and you could look at
your current situation on an app
and i would see that after you eat
certain foods of course your blood sugar
rises
and if i would go for a walk it would
blunt it or stop it like it was like it
was almost like a ticking time bomb i'd
look at this thing and i'm like checking
checking checking and all of a sudden
i'm like oh my gosh it's going from 80
to 90 to 100 to 110 120 and you're like
get walking and so you know it's like
you want to see what the food does to
your blood sugar to see if it spikes it
but then it's like a hit at critical
point and as soon as you start moving
around
it totally takes it down so you can kind
of back to back this with foods but
walking after you eat um i mean in the
meadow in the health and wellness they
call like post perennial you know so
it's it's super important it's really
good for it's just really good to to
blunt that blood sugar response so that
um
it doesn't spike
uh on the heels of that lesson number
three eat your fat and protein at the
beginning of your meal so this is
another thing that i learned from the
blood glucose monitor is that
the order of the food that you eat is
really important so if you eat your
carbohydrates first it hits your body
first and so
um eating fat and protein but but really
guys it was like a lesson definitely in
like making sure that there's fat in the
meals i could eat a meal that was like
chicken and spinach and
yeah chicken and spinach kind of thing
and it would spike my blood sugar more
than
other meals and i'm thinking like it's
just chicken and spinach and that's
because you know you're i mean your
blood does it does change with protein
it's like fats the only thing that
doesn't have any effect
but
but protein does have somewhat of an
effect and and carbohydrate carbohydrate
has even more
so i'd say make sure that you eat fat
and protein at the beginning of all your
meals to help with your blood sugar
response with food
lesson number four
is fasting windows so lesson number four
is 12 hour
rest periods
between uh eating windows
i mean i've i've done so much deep
diving into women and fasting windows
and you know there's some that do the
sun i do omad which is one meal every
day one one meal one meal every every
day
and then um
and then there's some that do like 18
hour fast some 16 hour fast 14
and really what what the the true like
most beneficial window is 12.
and in my in my review with ben he
definitely says that for me and
especially if you're a woman
in um
in your reproductive years that fasting
window getting too long can be
detrimental to your to the body and to
your hormones um so 12 hours of rest
between eating windows and then the
benefit of uh of four hours between
meals it actually kind of used to be
something that i would think in my head
because i would eat and then i think man
i'm kind of hungry and i'd look and i'd
be like
it's only been two hours though i should
probably hang on a little longer so i
would instinctively always think three
or four hours um
but four hours is the point in which
your bot your stomach has been able to
like turn over the bacteria and so if
you eat on top of that which is snacking
or just having meals too close
the gut bacteria doesn't have a chance
to do its thing and clean out and that
can lead to more bloating
so a little add-on is that yes i mean
the blood glucose monitor helped me
learn to not snack too because if you
have anything to eat you needed to check
it and everything you ate did something
to your blood sugar so
um
12 hour fasting windows um
between between your fasting windows and
then four hours between meals
all right lesson number five alcohol
reduces recovery
overnight and i learned this from
wearing a garmin watch and training for
the marathon
and
you know honestly one glass of wine can
disrupt your sleep and of course the
closer you are to to bedtime the worst
because like i would have a if i had a
glass you know before or like early
early early evening
before i ate and and that doesn't really
matter but if you're eating if you're
drinking a glass of wine after you eat
and going to bed even if it's a couple
hours later that wine definitely has an
effect on your sleep and so what i would
see in the data is i would see and a lot
of you wear wearables i'm sure if you
give a crap about this interview at all
it's because you care about health and
wellness and you probably have a
wearable um
but if you don't or if you isn't
something you pay attention to is your
your hrv your heart rate variability
or on the garment it was your body
battery you could see just how elevated
your heart rate was for so many hours
into the beginning of the night and then
finally halfway through the night or so
it drops off and then you finally start
to get recovery um but it really is
detrimental so if you're kind of on the
fence about that glass of wine after
dinner just skip it like it's it really
really does reduce recovery and if
there's one thing that i feel like is
probably the most common like number one
thing to do for your health is to get
good sleep so
i make wine but i still would say like
skip that one glass and just save it for
that night do you want to hit the bottle
you know just kidding maybe maybe not
maybe i do both it's just life don't
take it too seriously
um okay number six